now there are a lot of fitness gadgets
out there in my quest to get fit
I tested 17 of them over the last few
months at least one personal trainer I
know was a little bit skeptical yeah
I've been watching these new
technologies come to the market for
almost as long as I've been a personal
trainer they're just tricks and truths
they're not much different than the
Bowflex machines or to be honest the
original Jane Fonda workout video but
some of these gadgets that are just
coming to the market do so much more
than what they used to do just tracking
your activities out of all of them this
test strap was my favorite it comes with
a robot coach that points to the future
one where you might not need a human
trainer at all and it works like this
you wear the test strap so that it can
read your heart rate and that connects
the moves free app that talks to you
welcome to moutarde ratio doctor running
let's get into most computerized coach
tells you what to do at that exact
moment whether you're running outside or
you're doing bodyweight exercises
indoors when you're are faster to get
your legs moving quicker let's crush
this round and by reading your heart
rate she knows exactly how hard you're
working
she keeps you honest way to go you are
in the target zone
[Music]
keep pushing you're almost at the end of
the round don't give up I've been
running for seven years now and my
biggest problem is that I never push
myself hard enough and that's going on
the same slow comfortable 30-minute jobs
but the move
HR burn lasted me out of that rut by the
end of these half hour exercises I was
drenched in sweat in a way that I never
am when I workout alone
training with a real person is great
whether that's your group instructor or
your coach or your personal trainer but
humans they're expensive for the rest of
us this $60 gadget it's all you need
you